we just finished celebrating National
Women's small business month and
starting today it's military family
month and our next guest wears both hats
a successful Southern Nevada business
owner and she was in the military it's
Dede Clifton owner of the office Squad
hi Dede how are you
hi hi Mercedes how are you doing great
now tell us about the office Squad what
do you do
oh I'm very honored to be here and talk
about the office Squad the office Squad
is back office support for small
business owners we do everything from
answer the phones to full charge
bookkeeping and more that's amazing and
so tell me a little bit about how your
military experience helped you launch a
successful business
well I have a very unique position in
the Air Force I did it right out of high
school so I was a young whippersnapper I
worked behind this huge reception desk
with a flying schedule I answered the
phones took care of Radio Calls with our
F-15 pilots in the air help with the
schedule I think I said that data entry
for their pilot training even made the
coffee all those little things that need
to happen to keep a business or a
squadron running smoothly so I took that
experience and when I got out became a
military spouse I had to learn
bookkeeping to assist with some of the
volunteer things that I was doing so it
came got really good at QuickBooks and
it kind of it's amazing because I feel
like you serve as an inspiration to
other women who are looking at you
thinking wow I would love to be able to
do what she does do you have a tip for
those women that are really wanting to
do something but haven't quite taken
that leap yet
uh yeah just do it
um I have three things that I tell our
clients is to to just create systems and
procedures when you start your business
because that's how the military does it
you do the same thing over and over it
just becomes natural so make sure you
start that write it down number two
build a culture build a culture that you
believe in something that you are doing
not just to make money but to help
others and then number three is yeah
three care about the people the main
event is
your staff your clients your staff where
are they going how are you supporting
them that is just incredible advice
thank you so much for your time and
thank you for being such an inspiration
to all of those that are wanting to do
that lots of